two former Prime Minister's Tony Blair
and John Major are calling for a
referendum on britain's brexit deal to
give people a say on access to the
single market both argue that there is a
credible case for a second vote in a
magazine interview Tony Blair said it
can be stopped if the British people
decide that having seen what it means
the pain game cost benefits and benefit
analysis doesn't stack up adding why
wouldn't you keep your options open why
wouldn't you say we took this decision
we took it before we saw what its
consequences are now we see its
consequences we're not so sure so should
Britain have a second referendum on our
membership of the EU and in particular
the single market joining us now to
discuss this as Labour MP Gary Davies
who agrees with another referendum he
joins us from Cyprus advanced type also
joining us live from Westminster as bilk
Ashley Conservative MP who is against a
second vote good afternoon to you both
at gentlemen xml kesha why you against
it a second vote do you think that the
public given the information we have now
particularly given the autumn statement
this week might have changed their minds
and might think you know what we know a
bit more now we'd think differently well
first of all we've had a referendum and
we're not going to have a second one
Prime Minister's made that clear and
she's completely right the fact remains
that over a week ago sixty-eight percent
said they wanted to leave the EU that's
up from fifty two percent in the
referendum itself the referendum was
clear-cut there was a majority in favor
of leaving the European Union and people
like Tony Blair and John Major simply
don't get it in fact Tony blow himself
promised the referendum and then he
didn't give us one so for practical
purposes these people are past failures
gerund Davis let's put that to you Tony
Blair and John Major just don't get it
and actually more people now and then at
the time of the referendum want to see
us out of here you well I don't think
that's true after the Autumn Statement
lighting the Sun a majority is saying
they're not going to get what they were
promised they're gonna be worse off
pounds of debt they're being they
incomes I mean cover 5% by inflation and
they want to have the last say on the
deal not my pledge is that we should try
and allow the people the final word on
the deal not for that deal to be decided
behind closed doors because it's simply
not what people were promised and this
is a big decision we should put it back
to the people at Bell cash I mean when
it came to the vote back in June we
didn't really know what we were voting
for do we did we and actually does
anybody know what we were voting for
David Davis this week in Strasbourg
accused by the EU of not even
understanding what breaks it means
absolutely not the fact is that people
did understand and there were 62 percent
in my constituency said that they wanted
to leave and the majority was
significant but you know something but
wanted to leave to want it to leave in
order you have one kind of deal with you
well if we go back to what you were just
saying about the autumn statement and
the Office of Budget Responsibility and
then the Institute of fiscal studies
studies I think they're called who are
heavily subsidized by the way by the EU
and the EU institutions the fact is that
the people of this country made a
decision and they got it right because
it's about who governs Britain they
wanted to be able to govern themselves
and what follows from that is that we're
going to go through a process but we're
also going to have a repeal bill to
repeal the European communities at 972
and we're then going to be able to
govern ourselves and have a proper
democracy back that's what it's all
about we're not going to be governed by
a two-tier Europe largely dominated by
Germany that's what this is really all
about and it's about making sure that
the British people have the right to
decide on the government they want for
themselves and Tony Blair and John Major
are living on another planet going Davis
I mean we had a full and fair democratic
vote are these two out of touch
politicians trying to subvert the will
of the people well the people who are
promised 350 million pounds a week the
NHS in fact they go after it's going to
cost 200 and 300 million
in cost to them instead they were
basically sold a cup they've been misled
and people thought they were going to be
better off basically they have money
back but instead they're now being
they're going to have a cut something
like a thousand pounds in the future
plus the inflation cuts we've been told
pensioners now will be cut up to 20 20
this isn't what people voted for and
people of the right to have a final vote
on the deal on the table not sums of
destination unknown which is sort of
progressed by sort of wrecks it
fundamentalists like well care well i
got i have a proper say on the deal on
the table and it's their deal and not
touch to be done in private rooms by
bill in his mates well could I just add
to that just one point if you actually
look at what's happened with Nissan
glaxosmithkline what we've just heard
from Jaguar what we've heard from one
company after another they want to do
deals with the United Kingdom you want
to leave Britain if we go ahead because
we won't be a platform into the EU this
is a blank check people didn't vote for
a blank check and at any cost they
aren't fundamentalists like you fill the
people who want the best for their
families and now they know it's worse
for their families they should have a
final say on the final destination can I
parent Davies when you want that final
say to happen though because we've heard
from the Irish Prime Minister Enda Kenny
today that it will be impossible to
reach a deal between the UK and EU in
two years and he's talking about a
transition arrangement which may last
over three years well first of all the
artificially shouldn't be triggered
until the end of next year because as
soon as we do that we give in our EU
membership which means we've got new
negotiating power and the 27 EU say it
will decide what they want to give us
which will probably be bad because they
don't want anyone else to leave in terms
of the negotiations are article 50 as I
say we've got no power so the
negotiations need to occur before
article 50 the understanding you that
we'll have a referendum on the deal so
they've got incentive to negotiate well
I can only reply to that but if you look
at the trade deficit between ourselves
in the e between ourselves in the EU it
runs at 60 2 billion
pounds a year with the other 27 member
states that speaks for itself we have a
global surface with the rest of the
world and over 30 billion it went up by
about 10 billion last year alone the
bottom line is that the brexit
arrangements are good for Britain it's
about returning as the bit of people
have said to the people governing
themselves through general elections and
people can decide at general elections
whether or not they want a government or
they want to be able to govern
themselves and I see one last thing and
that is that with the EU you don't
govern yourself because all the laws
that come pouring in come from Brussels
that decided by majority vote of other
countries okay bill cash Garrett Davies
that's all we've got time for thank you
very much for joining us this afternoon